quand vous avez déclaré je trouve
formidable que des actrices de x est
aujourd'hui la possibilité d'aller
donner leur avis dans les émissions de
télévision et dans les magazines mais
nous aussi
bon alors vous avez fait un seul film et
vous êtes déjà une star non mon deuxième
film est sorti le 1er juin
ro donc il s'appelle la collectionneuse
et voilà c'est mon deuxième alors
pourquoi c'est devenu une star aussi
vite parce que vous n'êtes pas les les
sourcils trop maquillée pas les seins
refaits c'est ça je pense que on se
faisait une serre font se fait une
certaine image de la pornostar comme on
dit et moi j'ai gardé mon image et ça
étonne pas mal de banal de pas mal de
monde donc c'est peut-être une raison x
condé à ce que les gens attendent et
peut-être non une femme enfant peut-être
une personne qu'on peut croiser dans la
rue qui peut être n'importe qui pas
forcément quelqu'un destiné pour ça qu'à
travailler pendant des années j'arrive
j'essaie d'être naturel j'aime pas mon
image et ça a l'air de marcher j'ai mis
mes lunettes
alors votre premier film c'était projet
x avec fred coppula le réalisateur fred
coppula le deuxième la collectionneuse
j'imagine c'est aussi avec fred coppula
je vous ai signé pour trois films avec
lui bien plus est signé pour trois films
et on travaillera je pense toujours
ensemble parce qu'au delà de du métier
on est devenus de très grands amis il
est devenu une sorte de grand frère pour
moi
alors contrairement contrairement à
rafael à anderson qui était assise à
votre place ya quelques semaines qui
vient de publier hard chez grasset qui
marche très très bien d'ailleurs
vous n'êtes pas encore déçu par le
métier à vous je suis ravi parce qu'en
fait quand j'ai connu raphaël en 95 elle
était un peu comme vous ai trouvé ça
formidable maintenant là c'est à dire
que j'ai fait dans des conditions qui
sont très particulières et voilà je suis
consciente de sa part vous dites je fais
du bien à la pornographie qu'armand
plaisir se voit dans mes yeux
ouais j'espère en tout cas faire du bien
à pornographie au début c'était pas mon
objectif je suis arrivé comme ça pour
m'amuser et plus plus ça va plus je me
sens bien dans ma position j'ai envie de
faire du bien en même temps le monde du
golf à un but comme ça non mais alors ce
qu'il faut dire c'est que clara a une
particularité elle ne tourne qu'avec un
seul partenaire masculin c'est son mec
ces grecs santoro vous touareg avec lui
ben disons que à la base j'avais comme
objectif de tourner avec des personnes
dont j'avais envie donc forcément je
tourne avec mon ami et je dis pas que je
tournerai jamais avec personne d'autre
mais en tout cas ce qui est sûr c'est tu
tomberas avec départs sont dangereux
parce que c'est nécessaire pour moi lui
ton avec d'autres filles oui un café
vous dites je sais que dans sa tête
quand et avec les autres c'est vraiment
un travail oit sur la leyre ignorant
mais c'est à dire que je sais que la
personne qu'il aime c'est moi je sais
que si la direction s'est pas non plus
par hasard mais comme teurs j'entendais
la question que vous avez posé je pense
qu'il ya conquis le sexe sans amour
existe mais ça c'est autre chose
faire un film c'est pas comme si on
faisait l'amour pour de vrai
sans arrêt des coupures je veux dire
c'est faut être sur un tournage pour
comprendre ce qu'est un tournage qui
s'est passé tout pour les pour les
hommes de ce que font qu'il faut quand
même qu'ils gardent la gaule tout le
temps il ya des coupures que diane
coupures soit autant se mettent à 6h30
la peinture
c'est extra pour parler peut pas les
performances 1 j'ai un copain me connais
plein de gens dans le cinéma et qui ont
qu'il leur est arrivé de fait de tourner
dans des films ou de travailler dans des
films comme ça
x et il disait que les comédiens
s'astiquer le menhir tout le temps et
qui arrivait à garder la gaule pendant
des heures et des heures de la journée
c'est une sacré performance avec le coup
de chapeau c'est l'oeil de moi je trouve
qu'ils sont trop moi j'aimerais bien de
temps en temps qui met un mec normal
dans la bande
parce que parce qu'elle apprenne aux
femmes un nouvel disent ah bah oui mais
sur la cassette c'était plus gros ses
bureaux forcément cdc des bestiaux
d'élevage
quand même parce que moi j'aimerais bien
moi la maison je la prends moi quand je
la prends comme ça j'en vois encore un
bout un guide est pas ça mais moi et si
je mets deux mains moi je vois plus rien
il ya encore cinq idées pas c'est normal
moi non bien bien bien ça c'est fait
alors lorsqu'on avait deux donc mec
santoro il tourne avec d'autres filles
vous vous pensez donc effectivement
quand et avec elle ce n'est que du
travail et vous l'a dit toute façon et
si vous vous proposer de tourner avec
une énorme star du porno comme recours
par exemple c'est pas ce genre de
propositions qui m'intéresserait c'est
de toute façon c'est moi qui ferai la
démarche d'un parlement réalisateur dans
la mesure où un acteur me plairait
j'aurais envie de tourner avec lui c'est
assez difficile à croire mais c'est la
réalité une question de quoi le grain de
peau de et d'attirance comme on a dans
la vie on est à des personnes qui sont
différentes des autres vous l'échec avec
d'échangé pour votre amie clara c'est
évidemment plus facile pour lui et à
digérer je suis au travail s'il te plaît
ne ne m'appelle pas je nettoierai que je
suis au bureau mais c'est vrai qu'il a
aucune raison non mais sérieusement il a
aucune raison de ne pas être amoureux de
vous et vous vous de vous quitter
puisque de la mesure vous tous tout va
bien le charcutier du coin lui si jamais
elle a embrassé la boulangère en
cachette derrière l'église s'il se fait
gauler ces horreurs et l'a dit qu'est ce
que tu fais c'est vrai que je bosse
je rentrerai vers 7 heures départ parce
qu'on a encore deux fois il a la bonne
idée h le grade
c'est exactement ça oui alors vos
parents beaux-parents maintenant auprès
de vos parents vous dites avec mes
parents j'ai préféré jouer franc jeu
c'est mieux qu'ils ont vu la cassette
chez auchan
alors quelques mois auparavant vous
aviez déjà à vous et à votre mère votre
bisexualité oui la vida y voit la
première fois ben c'était pas trop
longtemps vent mais elle m'avait parlé
de quelque chose et moi j avais dit bon
il faut que je te parle de moi parce que
vont il ya des choses que tu sais pas et
c'est vrai que j'ai une attirance qui
vers les femmes
elle m'a dit qu'elle s'en doutait un peu
parce que c'est vrai que depuis que je
suis jeune j'ai beaucoup de copines
elles sont toutes jolies on sait pas
pourquoi
donc voilà mais julie avoué et
sincèrement et c'est vrai que quand on a
eu cette proposition pour monter sur
paris et tout ça je dédie aussi
directement ainsi qu'à mon père c'est
vrai qu'ils n'ont pas très bien pris
c'est normal ils ont préféré que soient
vos quatre quelque chose comme ça mais
bon au fur et à mesure du temps le
barreau est pas loin non plus
alors est ce que greg était avec vous
quand vous êtes allé voir vos pas oui on
est descendus ensemble on leur a dit ils
n'ont pas compris
normal mais on leur a expliqué montrer
et après ils ont beau y attendait si vos
parents vous aviez dit ce jour-là écoute
clara ont le plus de voir je n'aurais
jamais fait vous auriez arrêter le porno
c'est bien mais mes parents même trop
pour ça et ce qu'ils veulent c'est que
chaleureuse
ouais je pose la question à mes parents
tiens oui mais profitez-en qui vaille
c'est que je suis bi fabien quoi c'est
tout et aujourd'hui vous parler encore
et votre mère au téléphone vous appelez
des fois par an une fois tous les deux
jours
rien n'est obligé de garder ce contact
elles sont à votre voix vous êtes
heureuse que tout va bien
oui elle est montée sur paris je suis
descendu en très peu de temps sur
marseille dans l'entourage vos paroles
ya des gens qui leur disent ils dans ta
fille l'horreur c'est l'enfer parce que
je fais quelques chez pas mal de télé
quand même ce mois ci je fais cinq
couvertures de magazines je suis quand
même assez médiatisé pour une fille du x
et c'est vrai que c'est un énorme poids
pour eux quand même
moi j'aime peu l'impression de m'être
défilé en venant sur paris et de leur
avoir un petit peu imposé sa et c'est ça
qui me gêne c'est le regard des autres
quand j'ai eu une enfance heureuse à une
adolescence plutôt libre non les parents
ça c'est un petit peu froissé à mon
adolescence parce que moi j'avais besoin
de liberté de sortir avec mes copines le
soir tout ça et ça ça a été très
difficile
je suis pas sorti tout seul il a fallu
que je rencontre greg personnage et vous
aviez saison et que mes parents va être
qu'on soit bien semble qu'ils aient
confiance en lui pour me laisser sortir
et tout ça alors vous vous prépariez un
bts
merci commercial 8 et fonctionnaires
greg dans quoi après c'est le facteur
sonne toujours deux fois je n'ai pas
rencontré dans ce genre d et alors vous
aviez faire du naturisme au cap d'agde
ça c'était deux ans après entre m c'est
moi qui avais envie d'essayer parce que
moi je connais ça qu'à travers les
bouquins de films le ravallec de
houellebecq etc
mais non vraiment je pars du cap d'agde
de kara je parle j'étais les pintades
avec j'aimerais y aller c'est très sympa
c'est très sympa et jean centre et cinq
avaient été envoyés dès cet été
j'accueille en a marre oui j'aime
beaucoup d'amis là-bas et branché ouais
ok ce qui se passe au cap d'ail parce
que les gens savent pas tous
alors y'a rien camping et des hôtels
pour ceux qui ne veulent pas vivre tout
nu tout le temps et c'est vrai que le
soir il ya des boîtes un petit peu
particulière échangiste comme on dit et
on y va ou pas oui mais dans la journée
par exemple sur la plage au supermarché
ça baise non non pas du tout bon non il
ya un mélange québec de de pureté de
gens avec le naturisme et toute cette
culture et d'autres il sera pour les
gens qui prétendent également excellente
remontée du marché de prendre un blonde
les couilles de
de prendre un autre melon avec samantha
est un côté nature et que je mangeais
plus que c'est le rêve de c'est un peu
le rêve de tout le monde de passer
communiste de retirer ses mandats par
c'est un petit peu ça me fait penser à
l'époque des orgies romaines tout le
monde fait qu'ils voulaient mais jamais
personne n'est forcé on fait ce qu'on
veut quand on en a envie
c'est génial moi c'est la partie qui me
plaît c'est qu'on peut ne pas le seul
louis du vêtement ah non ça ce serait
vraiment oui ça ce serait le contraire
de la liberté quatre ans alors pour vos
vingt ans oui grec vous invite à paris
quiz pour retrouver des amis du cap
d'agde
ouais et alors là vous arrivez au salon
autre vidéo pour voir des copains toi on
est montés pour aller au salon une vidéo
parce qu'en s'intéressaient de près ou
de loin ce milieu et on voulait aussi
voir paris une espèce de vocations
femmes déjà chez vous pas forcément
je pense la vocation c'était au niveau
de l'esprit libre et une certaine
ouverture d'esprit je pense c'était là
et c'est ce jour là où on a rencontré
fred coppula dans ally thater qui
déboule en à regarder paris cinq minutes
c'est exactement ça on n'a même pas du
tout paris alors quand on vous parle du
sexe vous dites vous demande ce que vous
préférez dans le sexe vous dites je
préfère rien j'aime tout petit pas
vraiment vrai que si c'est vrai oui à
des trucs qui me plaisent pas danger pas
un détail y'a n'ont pas de détails pas
forcément il ya une fraude en
particulier qui ne me plaît pas vraiment
voilà
mais à part ça j'aime j'aime pas une
chose en particulier parce que ce serait
ses limites et j'aime un ensemble de
choses au niveau de la sexualité mais
bien les différentes ambiances et
revisite certains jours j'aime bien
d'être happé par surprise puis joe
toujours attaché c'est greg vie et les
bandes et les yeux non j'aime bien les
deux côtés oui j'aime bien jouer
oui vous aimez fred coppula j'ai
beaucoup suivi sa carrière
robert j'ai cru que je trouve que
mademoiselle a quand même un plan de
carrière si ça rigole pas c'est quand
même pas je dois y est vous hier maria
la baleine est bien là vous savez qu'on
ne bouge pas pendant le jingle en f1
pendant les ting
[Applaudissements]
on ne bouge pas bon non mais jean galle
bien ça c'est fait
alterview première fois premier souvenir
ma première fois à tout de suite c'est
bah oui c'est un grand truc dont on
parle de sexe au gip ans alors mais ça
aurait pu être sympa moi je trouve et
avant 13 ans vous avez commencé tard en
plus 15 ans et demi sans perdre celle du
premier choc de votre vie c'est pas
obligatoirement du sexe on ya pas
longtemps ce qu'avec un membre de ma
famille
je voulais me suis retenu est valable le
budget n'est premier mensonge il n'a pas
duré longtemps c'est une tromperie le
trompe et vague
oui non mais ça du rêve de jours que
j'ai dit je vais jouer
on est déçus il a fait avant moi
cédric sont durs en tête premier péché
de gourmandise sacrée première main mon
papa ouais premier coup de foudre
greg grèce aux grecs quand même premier
baiser sans la langue sans la langue
sans la langue c'était à tort bon j'ai
commencé avec la langue
j'avais déjà mon mac comme indice ma
boîte et attendez je sais tu es en 4e
qu'elle faisait vielmon pas quel âge
la maison est alors maintenant aux
primes et avec la langue avec la langue
avec la langue si tu n'étais pas un an
pour la première fois alors donc c'est
avec greg
oui à l'âge de 16 ans oui je dis oui
comme ça parce qu'il ya une un essai
avec quelqu'un d'autre mais c'était un
très mauvais souvenir
ah bon c'est pas bien passé la première
vraie foi voilà les premières fois avec
une fille c'était pour la thune faire
c'était pour l'anniversaire de greg je
comprends pas comment on pourrait se
voir plus souvent préparé un petit
cadeau
exactement c'est une fille dont j'avais
envie et finalement c'était pas prévu on
était dans une soirée tout ça et on est
rentrés tous les trois voilà qui sont
pas vus à gré il ya un bravo et
félicitations des béni des dieux
vous rentrez jamais qu'un copain vaincu
problème avec le pain oui il pourrait
avoir envie de rentrer avec un copain
vague aussi fort et que ce soit moi qui
en ai envie ah bon c'est vous qui
décidez oui je pense que c'est normal
dans un couple que ce soit la femme la
femme a plus besoin de choses pour le
sexe comme un homme c'est assez facile
et pas mal c'est bien enfin souvent une
fille a plus besoin d'eux des choses
pour la première fois à troyes vous
venez de le dire première fois 4 enfin
tout dire c'était y'a pas longtemps et
a5 jamais ah bon vous êtes tout à
apprendre encore
première scène de ménage quand même
j'espère passer à londres dans un beau
coup depuis
ouais on discute beaucoup hein on aime
bien vous aimez bien pour la
réconciliation merci bien sûr les
premiers amours c'est qui votre vrai
premier amant sur pareil non bah oui
hélas
c'est fred coppula
et avec vous
mais maintenant à chacun de viol ou
d'une star du porno
voici car à morgane
non
un organe julie john raese gérard darmon
voilà alors donc ça fait un an que je
vais arrêter de tourner toute la france
regrette évidemment cette décision clara
morgane
heureusement on a les cassettes à la
maison on allait on a les dvd à gérard
centre baudelaire et musset voilà c'est
bien rangés dans tous les cas alors la
première raison de l'arrêt de votre
carrière c'est que vous ne faites plus
un couple avec greg santoro votre fameux
jules on y reviendra d'ailleurs mais bon
comme vous vouliez tourner qu'avec lui
évidemment quand vous êtes plus ensemble
ou tourner plus j'ai une première raison
la deuxième raison c'est que vous avez
plus envie non c'est une perte pour le
cinéma je peux vous le dire clara
morgane non mais sérieusement je détiens
imposer très rapidement un ouais c'est
vrai d'un succès fulgurant ouais j'ai
une notoriété assez rapide et notamment
grâce à vous ce que j'ai fait des télés
c'est la mission du service public
non c'est la même chanson j'ai fait très
rapidement des télés c'est ça qui m'a
permis de me faire connaître ce sens les
médias ont rien fait bien alors donc
aujourd'hui vous présenter le journal du
hard sur canal + en + genre quittez pas
quand même trop facilement le milieu
enfin non non vous regarder ce que font
les copines vous faites des spectacles
dans les discothèques tous les week-ends
specter un genre de strip tease
améliorer on va dire faut que j'aille
voir ça devant les journalistes il faut
vraiment aller sur le terrain je crois
moi même je comprends pas très bien et
alors vous avez écrit un livre il
voulait dire quelque chose y avait la
bouche qui a bougé et aucun sens car il
se voir
ssa iv en fait il est possible qu'au
musée après bon morgan vous écrivez un
livre qui s'appelle sexe car et c'est
aux éditions attaquant mesdames
messieurs
[Musique]
alice que je vous conseille de gérard
darmon merci ouais c'est en quelque
sorte la bible de clara morgane s'est
par exemple possible
c'est une espèce de somme alors vous
raconter votre vie depuis votre
naissance à marseille en 1981 vos
parents coiffeur sur le vieux port
tout un poème des gens on voit bien
l'ambiance ya quelque chose à l'om
banyoles la vidéo m oui et alors une
enfance parfaitement heureuse parce que
souvent on dit les filles qui font du
porno elles ont été malheureuse en a en
france pas du tout un bon parent très
sympa le seul choc de votre vie enfin
j'ai trouvé ça dans le bouquin c'est la
mort de votre grand mère c'est pas un
truc bon c'est terrible toutes les
grands-mères finissent par mourir mais
moi ça m'avait plu 85 à une autre
d'autres gens d'ailleurs depuis la mort
de cette grand mère vous continuez à
croire en dieu mais vous n'êtes plus
jamais allé ni au catéchisme clara
morgane ni à la messe
ceci explique peut-être cela permettez
moi de dire d'un seul coup à l'âge de 11
ans le catéchisme et la messe voilà où
ça mène alors l'âge de 12 ans au fait
pourquoi tu es en photo la presse locale
me tuera tous que c'est la bonne classe
ouais y'a langage du corps chez gérard
casse expression qui truquent accès aux
quais pour le week-end d'accord ok
attendait 4 la cua gérardmer plus que
quatre
donc effectivement 12 ans les premières
photos dans la presse locale 14 en
modèle pour des robes de mariée dans une
petite gloire locale robe de mariée ils
prennent toujours des jaloux site très
de 14 15 mais attendez serge et marie
pierre sueur voilà ce qu'est ce que je
peux voir ce qui vient de se passer est
ce que je peux avoir un petit replay
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et puis un jour et puis un jour clara
morgane c'est le déclic
vous allez au manhattan qu'est qu'un
club d'après midi à marseille halal et
là vous découvrez vous êtes obligés d
après midi mais c'est pareil en après
midi vient l'argent et dans ce club
d'après midi donc à l'argent les adultes
face une autre vie pour vanter la
découverte de l'aude
regarde moi ok c'est pas le même usage
découverte du monde des adultes et la
transition de l'enfance ase aux jeunes
adultes on va arrêter
c'est infernal des mois est ce que régis
peut venir s'il vous plaît régis mais je
publierai g102m non et puis greg à la
grecque c'est notre chanson police y
santoro non si le partenaire de clara
dans les films il vous a vraiment révélé
à votre sexualité comme on dit chez nous
dans d'autres émissions et qui brille
mais voilà et la première fois vous
faites l'amour avec lui c'est une
véritable illuminations avec l'a7 à
l'époque à l'époque
donc voilà et là c'est là que ça
commence les histoires parce que
jusque-là bon et là vous partez pas
pourquoi vous allez faire du naturisme
mais au lieu d'aller faire du naturisme
chez les naturistes vous allez au cap
d'agde le plus grand aucun nom mais au
cap d'agde c'est comme avant tout un
grand centre naturiste
ouais donc après la nuit bon il ya autre
chose mais là la journée c'est un grand
sont naturistes âgées des familles là
pour combien d'habitants au cap d'agde
et et 25 personnes
mais si le plus grand ami à 25000
personnes qui buzz non mais vous vous y
êtes allé non je vais lui fait
rencontrer madame anna non le week-end
non mais le week end armes
il connaît très bien gérard je suis né
au cap d'agde
au début j'avais 17 ans et demi à
l'époque art au début vous pratiquez pas
du tout l'échangisme
vous êtes simplement exhibitionniste
c'est à dire que vous aimez avec greg
faire l'amour devant d'autres gens n'est
jamais avec d'autres gens je parle du
début donc greg rapidement lui en
revanche il est conquis par les
chantiers mais l'échangisme c'est quoi
c'est on se fait un truc
il ya des couples qui ont besoin de
d'autres couples pour avoir une
sexualité débridée parce que ça fait des
années qu'ils sont ensemble pour un tas
de raisons il ya des couples qui ont
besoin d'autres personnes dans leur
sexualité
moi c'est quelque chose que j'ai jamais
ressenti personnellement mais ça me
faisait rire de voir et là vous
découvrez que vous aimez aussi les fans
c'est quelque chose que j'avais en moi
depuis très longtemps
oui
qu'est ce que tu veux qu'on nous cache
quelque chose que j'ai toujours ressenti
en fait mais que j'ai pas vraiment
assumé très rapidement je voulais pas
trop y penser ça mais ça va j'ai
toujours une petite attirance vers les
femmes aussi
voilà on à ce point comme un mois voilà
bombay la suite tout le monde la connaît
oui c'est la légende des jambes mais
clara morgane on la connaît c'est à dire
qu'un jour tu as dit jack joel bois
ovidie à la télé elle se dit mais le
cinéma porno c'est peut-être pas match
voilà au même moment il ya eu pas que
c'est vachement utile c'est même
comprendre et déclenché des vocations
au même moment il ya le salon hot vidéo
à paris elle monte avec greg salon est
vidéo à paris il rencontre marc dorcel
je me porte bien de mes filles je la
connais par coeur votre légende noire
vous l'avez lu avec attention à bien sûr
pourquoi non ces trois messieurs livre
là j'ai fait très attention c'est ce que
je lis en entier oui ça m'a bien plu
c'est un bon voilà donc une belle soirée
mario recèle y danser sur les tables et
vous séduisez tout le monde et à ce
moment là marc dorcel vous propose de
tourner pour lui et vous dites moi je ne
tourne qu'avec mon jules je ne tourne
qu'avec gré à gré avant ça c'était déjà
après réflexion c'est vrai que j'ai eu
envie de me lancer dans cette aventure
avait pas avec marc dorcel avec fred
coppula vous connaissez fred coppula
mais qu'est-ce que vous avez jamais au
cinéma puis la comco culé oui voilà un
peu coppola et copé voilà vous accepté
le deal l'huile l'acceptent tout va bien
vous allez donc tourné avec rennes
cet extravagant voilà c'est le début de
la gloire vous voulez tout
issu des
[Musique]
car à bonal une carafe coup mais greg
lui comprend qu'il ne sera toujours que
le fiancé de clara morgane
ouais et puis alors le succès ne change
complètement ce grec santoro face est ce
que vous dites dans votre livre est
alors il ya un truc que je savais pas
grosses formations non parce que je
savais pas c'est que ses ardeurs bon ils
foncent à toute la journée
1 donc on pourrait penser que césar
suffit n'est pas du tout avec le matin
quand il se réveille
la première chose qu'ils font sous la
douche c'est je parle évidemment pour
certains assurent non mais enfin si greg
aussi le matin en se réveillant c'est
très étrange ça devient une drogue pour
eux le matin en se réveillant sous la
douche bon après ils vont travailler et
le soir quand ils reviennent bonsoir
arrive
soit ils ont une femme soit ici il se
paye une prostituée sahara est ce que tu
peux imaginer qu'un mec est souvent
c'était les mêmes que les gens ça
deviens complètement obsessionnelle sur
la main et ils bandent content voilà
là j'ai l'impression d'être dans le
coeur des hommes c'est exact voilà le le
filtre à sable
voilà et aujourd'hui vous êtes avec fred
coppula way et vous dit en parlant de
fred coppula c'est mon run est un peu
comme céline dion parle de son run et je
connais pas fred coppula mais j'espère
qu'il est mieux crever c'est quelqu'un
de très tendre c'est bon café les
parents dont le parrain ouais ouais
ouais donc vous avez une question très
personnelle
est ce que pour réussir dans le porno il
faut coucher
[Rires]
est ce que pour devenir une star de
porno faveur du q est ce que quand vous
rentriez le soir avec grec santoro à la
maison vous aviez l'impression de
ramener du boulot à la maison
non est-ce qu'on refusant la sodomie
vous privez pas les scénaristes d'un
ressort dramatique important parce que
c'est facile d'écrire un film porno sens
au demi maintenant je m'en fous
cher
alors maintenant car à morgane il va
falloir vous confesser interview c'est
le mot est très juste qu'on fait si
clara morgane avez vous déjà pêché par
penser par action ou par omission par
les trois à parler avez-vous commis le
péché d'adultère
une fois on choque ça il faudra voir une
petite chérie des mariés oui il faudrait
quand même petit pénitence pour ça on en
parlera après en cinq ans du
confessionnal mais je mettrais bien une
petite pénitence mois pour avoir pêché
en turquie namsa caraman regarde
avez-vous à coupiac suez veut accomplir
des actes contre nature
non jamais car à morgane est ce que vous
avez dit des mots grossiers comme beat
ou couilles pour tout le monde sans
reculer ce monde tout ça pour la grotte
pénitence est d'accord est-ce que vous
avez déjà été excité par un animateur de
télévision jeux rien non est-ce que vous
avez déjà été excité par un acteur oui
accord morgan dexter
audition
j'aime
et c'est vrai que c'est assez libertines
l'un être divertis
[Musique]